[Music]
cringy campaign news gingy come
submitted by I love JK so a painfully
awkward campaign ad has the internet
cringing called it the worst campaign ad
of the 2018 election
I love cringy ads right yeah I love it
what's one that you can remember that
you can tell us at the top of your head
like those uh part commercial oh yeah
yeah well like remember the the guy that
rapped about the furniture
yeah yeah there's a one like it's a it's
like a retail shop it's like a thrift
shop or some sort moves it's just a
bunch of white people and this thing was
just terrible and the dancing was
terrible and the video is terrible but
jingles they [ __ ] war yesterday for
no reason I was driving off have a good
nicely first one I've never heard that
one Matt just discounters discolored
this is easy one no now I want to hear
all the other jingles around the whole
country or Chia Pets - dick - GU oh yeah
they don't have those anymore for the
best color yeah they've talked about
what conviction yeah
I I what is it it's my money and I want
it now you'll probably start seeing them
when you start watching [ __ ] with taiga
oh yeah sure it's like regular TV it's
it's so kids start saying the jingles
like Isaac would memorize commercials
for toys and I'm like how do you know
that we don't even have TV at home how
do you know that oh yeah
it's the commercials they're so [ __ ]
cheap and shitty but it's just that
jingle that's all you need so lit like
you're really gonna take fires in every
best [ __ ] cuz I didn't have it but my
[ __ ] neighbor did I [ __ ] hate that
kid remember the monster candy maker oh
yeah I remember that [ __ ] I think the
brains and the green slime and spiders
oh yeah so anyway this video it's to
promote the campaign of a Democrat
hopeful in Virginia so his name is Dan
Hilmer what's the last time you ever
thought of Virginia or New Hampshire or
or what is it Vermont
maybe if we lived in the East Coast we
just yeah does anyone know anyone I feel
like there's no crime in New Hampshire
Vermont no yesterday Vermont in k-town
oh yeah my cousin lived in Virginia for
a minute yeah yes Dakota from North
Dakota
mmm-hmm I know attack Montana who the
[ __ ] goes to Montana hey man I love
people from there less people in the
rest days or South Dakota because they
have less people and in the whole state
than we do in some of our cities it's
only like population 20,000 or something
like that yeah
making Vermont I forgot that Vermont
existed yeah I forgot all the time until
I watched shows that are facing New York
and then they say that they're gonna go
to Vermont you know you know one that's
I think everyone doesn't know hmm
Nebraska Nebraska I know one person from
the courthouse Oh
you guys wanna watch this again yeah hit
that play bania that's Top Gun helmert
son that's doe here we go that's not
cringy here you go congressman Comstock
oh hi mark
hey Dan
sure is bet you can't get her to hold
down home town hall do you one better
than that we've lost
[Applause]
parenthood nice work Dan thanks maverick
I think it was supposed to be a joke
Town Hall's
bad singing and this message no I it's
because they didn't go over the top
enough yeah they're kind of teetering
cuz like I kind of like it actually yeah
see what they were going through yeah
you're not sure if you're serious or
it's supposed to be bad it's right there
in the middle he's like [ __ ] it
yeah so I'm gonna show you guys people's
reaction tweets to this
right would you like to read Dan I like
you this is not a good ad please fire
whoever thought it who ever thought it
was it was you take a vacation if it was
you if nothing else kid it's better than
a lot of the instagrams gifts that I've
seen actually I know a lot of buyers are
going to YouTube it's just not it's not
funny I think it's just harder to do you
know you know 10-second to five minutes
is so big it's just I've never found any
of it funny the few people out there
they maybe humor for like little kids
though I feel like a lot of younger kid
yeah type of humor and also they're just
binding off a whole JK skits as an
opponent of the GOP I plead with you dub
this ad is embarrassing and insulting we
want you to win this won't do it in your
bathroom dear God why would you do this
to yourself Dan Heller's ad started off
weird then became awkward disturbing and
how and now though said I watch the damn
thing very bizarre and it's working
though people are remembering yeah so
bad is actually good from a PR view this
ad is pretty awesome nobody has heard of
Dan helmet or 24 today true I don't know
who the hell he was weird it's so like
flip-floppy because it's not like this I
can make you remember or it's that one
well who's that one politician that went
yeah simplest thing and he got rude I
just remember Dave Chappelle me one of
them name yeah but that whole [ __ ]
god torch because of that though it
wasn't a good move room he didn't punch
a baby in the face you know it's just
this random reported that is he actually
did bad because of that it was a bad
move forever I love Barbara Comstock but
full disclosure i legit really love the
Dan home read it's one of those it's so
bad it's good yeah but who knows it's a
different world not to I feel like
negative press is good press note or
that catch me outside girl
yeah bad by Bobby usually like a record
multi-millions she go
yeah a multi-million dollar deal they
should all pound Clorox I feel like
they're all just big practical jokes and
everyone's laughing at them so when they
perform I was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're actually the [ __ ] yeah funniest
thing about it she's like me because I'm
so talented and I'm so sad
know what I'm doing whenever she's a 16
year old that just made seven figures
she's not even 16 she's like 14 okay
well I'm gonna die now thank you she
really made a million I think she made
six or seven figures yeah I wish I think
it's like told my parents that yeah I
mean hey can I just crash thank you on
this TV show yeah I will make a lot of
money minimum you wouldn't work back
then though oh yeah like this time you
got to be young and you got to have big
boobs like she did for like a 16 year
old girl her tits were huge I think she
was 13 which is on this show yeah 13
look like such a hooker at 13 cash
malabon the same I think all girls go
through a young hooker phase but she
wasn't she was like an adult hooker
looking girl like I passed for 18
probably easy yeah yeah that's a trap
waiting to happen dude I know she came
out on like how does she have that wreck
at 13 how she had ever brought a rack
early sag you later don't worry about it
true true but anyways if you guys would
see this politicians adding you're in
your hood would you guys what fam
absolutely not I'm solely because I
don't pay attention to politics and I'll
only remember his name it's like I
whatever others marked as long as I
remember the stupid Eskimos it's a bad
American I do the same I like a
politician that can that has a sense of
humor yeah sure
cuz it kind of humanizes them and
they're not like this [ __ ] lying sack
of robot [ __ ] can you watch that thrift
store video this one I cause this is
about the whitest thing possible and I
work
[Music]
it sound like a service to the customers
to make them feel alright I'm buying all
these products with oh so much delight
oh god I can help you find anything I
want to go shop here decided I just feel
like the whole service service is
selling service I'll be so mad if
they're not doing that when I walk
where's the dingle guy where do dancing
turn around
maybe she was shy and she's like okay
[Music]
that's awesome yeah
is that like a like a Michaels or like a
craft store in life you know what's
funny like I look at the two old white
couple and I already know what that
house smells like oh yeah yeah it's a
brown couch that's really scratchy like
if I go to that house I'm gonna be bored
to death it's not like don't milk yeah
it's like when you look at like Asian or
Chinese people you know like I know what
your house yeah what's up you sexy
[ __ ] useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to follow us you could check
out all our [ __ ] links in the
description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]